có là ít, có phòng lạ ít thì, có có mồn để mấy chiếc đả cho
tất, mấy phạch thì, đúng như thế giang giảm phó rận đào.
Nếu thế giang giảm phó rận đào, thế giang giảm phó rận đào,
và những cái chiếc phí khác, không chỉ phí, tay chính là,
có rất rất nhiều khó bình như phái, thì chúng ta sẽ có vấy
giữ điện để mà, chúng ta 1, 2, 3,
để chiếc đảm phó rận, không có đặc,
rất nhiều hành lắm, cho các bạn,
rất nhiều hành lắm, để xe mở tị, để vây trích tọng,
và nhìn, số cái trách đợi phó tý lệ và hành bài ca,
và trị, những những lợi trình phó rận đào,
rất nhiều hơi, rất nhiều hơi, cái tay xa,
rất nhiều đàn pháp tiền, rất nhiều cây phần đợi,
nó chỉ phía cây, thì nó, thì phạm anh là dễ,
Đáng thiếu vụ
Rất nhiều đáng cần
Vai đi
Mới rọng
Chúng ta sẽ có khả ngắn là
Vá mừng cho cái giv vầy nó ăn mong
Vá mừng lại đi
Cái rợi đáng
Chúng ta sẽ không có thể hạp sĩ
Chúng ta sẽ không dẫn
Bỏ cái tịt đi